as the entire American economy freezes
the feds open up the spigot we examine
what comes next and the media won't stop
labeling from / racist over his use of
the term Chinese virus I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't like the government spying on you
well visit expressvpn comm slash men to
stay safely anonymous alrighty well
today I really want to examine in depth
what exactly we are going to do from
here on out because that is eminently
unclear and let me just make clear at
the outset that I'm very much in favor
of measures that are designed to flatten
the curve I'm very much in favor of the
attempts to lower the threshold of death
you know that the goal here is to
prevent as that we've said before the
giant curve that exceeds the capacity of
the medical system from taking place in
to flatten that thing out but let's just
be realistic about what is going to work
for the American public and what is not
going to work for the American public I
was talking to my wife this morning
about this entire situation and I was
suggesting that if you look to the world
of of dieting what you know about
dieting what everybody knows about
dieting is the dieting doesn't work the
reason the dieting generally does not
work is because there is no end date it
is interminable and it is unrealistic if
you actually want to succeed in cutting
weight you either have to have rounds of
cutting away where you sent for three
weeks
we're just gonna cut wait for three
weeks it's gonna be no sugar there's
mean no fat there's I mean no carbs it's
gonna be brutal but you can do it for
three weeks and then you'll go back to
eating some of this stuff and you'll
adjust your lifestyle a little bit but
essentially you'll go back to kind of
quasi normal if you'd say that to people
then people can handle it for like three
weeks and if you say to people listen
we're gonna have to adjust your entire
diet and it's gonna be permanent but
it's not gonna be like enormous changes
it's just gonna be enough changes that
it changes the trajectory of your
nutritional health if you say to people
okay we're gonna cut we're not gonna cut
carbohydrates completely out but we're
gonna cut them down fairly significantly
we're not gonna cut out your morning cup
of coffee but we're gonna take down the
size of that cup of coffee that is
something people can deal with too if
you tell them on a permanent basis let's
be realistic about what we can do it and
we'll implement that on a permanent
basis here's what people cannot do we're
gonna cut out fat we're gonna cut out of
sugar we're gonna cut our gonna cut out
carbohydrate so we're gonna kind of cut
out salt and cut out everything that
tastes good to you and we're gonna do it
until I say no one's gonna do that
that's gonna last five minutes
truly five minutes and the reason it's
gonna last five minutes is because if
you believe that there is no in that
there's an indefinite wait time here at
a certain point you're just gonna say
okay screw it right really like done and
that is the prob
but the government's response with
regard to coronavirus thus far there
have been two major problems one is the
resources have not been brought to bear
I'll get to that in a moment because the
goal here as I was saying yesterday on
the program theoretically should be to
shift from sort of the Chinese model or
the Italian model of the French model to
the South Korean model and to do that as
fast as possible and the goal here would
be to move away from the model where
everybody is in complete lockdown where
you're isolated in your home where there
is tremendous amounts of social
distancing and to move toward the South
Korean model where there's heavy testing
and basically we are segregating off the
population that is exposed to the virus
from a population that is not exposed to
the virus so that over time you develop
a herd immunity and also so that you
don't shut down the economy that can
only happen when you have the resources
at your disposal so that should be the
goal the problem is if the government
doesn't actually lay out a timeline for
when that's going to happen it's gonna
be unrealistic and when you're talking
about millions of Americans losing their
job and that's what's gonna happen over
the next few weeks right the government
can backstop this stuff as much as they
want everyone knows that if this lasts
for six months the government is not
going to have the ability to simply keep
paying people I mean look at the bond
yields the bond yields are already
rising that means the desire to buy
American bonds is already down that
means buying American debt is down so
who's gonna finance all of the spending
you can do this for a short period of
time you can back stop bank loans for
example tell the banks don't call in all
of your loans right now tell the credit
card companies don't go and and police
all of your credit for a month or two
you can't do that for six seven eight
months not when nobody is working and
right now small businesses that were
operating with slim margins has great
lie that was being told by so many folks
on the Left that small business owners
or even major business owners are
operating on massive profit margins they
just got pools of cash stacked up
somewhere and they can pay people well
right now they're laying off tens of
thousands of workers and over the next
few weeks you're gonna see them allow
hundreds of thousands of workers and all
of the Democrat attempts to create
legislation that will force small
companies to pay for paid sick leave how
many companies do you think are just
gonna say okay not only we're not gonna
pay for paid sick leave we are not going
to employ you we're just gonna furlough
you about as people have to choose
between the risks of coral virus and the
rewards of having a job as that
calculation becomes more and more
immediate which is going to be overtime
the government is going to have to lay
out a timeline for how long this thing
last we're gonna
lay out a plan for what comes next
because it is just not going to be
sufficient to tell people hunker down
into your in your home until further
notice not unless these statistics
really start to show such a major uptick
that we're not just talking about the
the curve exceeding the the medical
community's capacity to deal with
coronavirus but we start talking about
mass death and the kinds of numbers that
sort of the worst case scenarios have
posited and right now people are looking
at the Cova 19 maps and they're saying
to themselves okay like really and this
is not I think unrealistic again none of
this is an argument not to stay home
right now if you can now to wash not sit
now to not wash your hands obvious
should be doing the social that all you
should do all of these things the point
I'm making is there has to be a mid term
or long term plan or even the short term
plan is going to fail again to go back
to the diet analogy if you want this
diet to work you're gonna have to tell
people when they can relax the diet
you're gonna have to tell people when we
come out of this and what life is gonna
look like when you come out the other
side of this if instead it's like okay
or an emergency situation until further
notice at a certain point people are
gonna be like no that's not going to
work it's sort of like the episode of 30
rock where Liz Lemon is on a plane she's
dating Matt Damon's character as a pilot
at the time she's on a plane and the
plane isn't taking off for hours at a
time Matt Damon keeps getting on the
horn every 45 minutes and saying 45
minutes to take off and eventually Liz
Lemon goes to the cockpit and she says
wait a second it's been three hours yeah
we just keep telling people 45 minutes
and she ends up bleeding and uprising on
the plane against Matt Damon that's what
you're going to see you're going to see
people basically say screw it like
really I'm just gonna go out I'm gonna
live my life I'm trapped at home I have
no job now what do you expect me to do
and that's not completely unrealistic so
right now people are looking at the at
the global pandemic and they're saying
there have been according to Johns
Hopkins 223 thousand cases confirmed and
about 90 100 deaths confirmed on a
planet of seven billion people and in
the United States we are currently
looking at somewhere around 10,000 cases
and south of 200 deaths and if those
numbers do not spike dramatically forget
about whether this is right or wrong or
the incapacity of people to understand
exponential thinking and the fact that
this thing could multiply pretty quickly
which of course it obviously could if
people look at this and we are at the
end of March and there have been less
than 500 deaths in the United States
less than a thousand deaths in the
United States and we have started to
level off in terms of the number of
cases that we are see
diagnosed each and every day then
there's going to be a real push from
people to get back to work
because this is not and if the
government does not set out exactly what
they are doing and why they're doing it
and when we can expect this thing to
relax people are going to take matters
into their own hands because these these
measures are extraordinarily restrictive
and you can be extraordinarily
restrictive for a short period of time
you cannot do it in a free country for a
long period of time
not again when you are talking about
destroying the economy to the tune of
according to JPMorgan a negative 14%
growth rate in q2 okay which is
unprecedented in American history
including during wartime
and we're gonna get some more of this in
a second we're gonna bring you some of
the news surrounding coronavirus and
where the spikes are happening and all
the rest first let us talk about the
fact that even during downtime think
particularly during particularly during
down times you need to make sure that
your company is staffed correctly and
this is why you need a zip recruiter so
let's say that you have a bunch of
narrow do well employees who are mostly
just excited to go home when there is a
when there is a global pandemic they're
like yeah I could do half the work and
and in half the time and then you think
yourself well all these people are now
working from home and we're just as
efficient and they're working like four
hours a day so maybe I could find more
efficient employees zip record calm
would be the way to make all of this
happen zip recruiter comm slash at daily
wire makes hiring great people faster
and easier today you can try zip
recruiter for free at zip recruiter comm
slash daily where when you go to zip
recruit with one click you send your job
to zip recruiters network of over 100
leading job sites what happens next
zip recruiter finds the best matches for
your job and then invites them to apply
it's so effective that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter can
equality candidate within the very first
day now is a great time to think about
the efficiencies of your business I mean
it's gonna be a rough ride for the rest
of the years give me a lot of downs and
hopefully a lot of ups right now is the
great time to staff your company
correctly try zip recruiter for free my
listeners can go to zip recruiters comm
slash daily wire that is zip recruiter
comm slash Dai ly WI re zip recruit comm
slash daily wear and make sure that your
company is staffed properly because when
we come out of this the economy is going
to boom and you're going to want to make
sure that your company is well staffed
zip recruiter comm slash daily wire zip
recruiter is indeed the smartest way to
hire ok so it's particularly true the
government needs to come up with a
timeline considering the fact that China
is now reporting zero community
infections i total what that suggests is
that we are now looking at the
possibility of seriously tamping this
thing now now is worthwhile noting here
that there are a bunch of other
countries that are seeing secondary
spikes so Singapore Hong Kong Taiwan all
of which looked to have had this thing
under control when people are coming
back into their country with corona
virus the thing is spiking again but so
far at least of China's not lying which
who the hell knows honestly China's
reporting zero local infections which is
a major turning point according to the
New York Times for the first time since
the corona virus crisis began China on
Thursday reported no new local
infections to the previous day a
milestone in its costly battle with the
outbreak that has since become a
pandemic a pending daily life economic
activity around the world
Apple has reopened all of its stores in
China officials said 34 new coronavirus
cases had been confirmed all involving
people who had come to China from
elsewhere and signaling that an end to
China's epidemic might be in sight the
announcement could pave the way for
officials to focus more on reviving the
country's economy which nearly ground to
a halt after the government imposed
travel restrictions and quarantine
measures in recent days economic life
has been resuming in fits and starts
according to the New York Times experts
say it will need to see at least 14
consecutive days without new infections
for the outbreak to be considered truly
over it still remains to be seen whether
the virus will realign Sayle life
restarts and travel restrictions are
lifted around the country and that's
gonna be the big question right I mean
if this thing just reeked crops up if it
keeps cropping up continuously at a
certain point people are gonna have to
go back to work and we're going to have
to live with the results of people going
back to work so hopefully what we're
doing right now is buying time in the
United States to build more ICU beds to
make sure that everybody has the medical
masks we are we are ensuring that the
the resources that are necessary to
raise the bar on medical care are
available that's what we're doing we're
buying time we are not actually
preventing the spread of the disease
beyond a certain point because when
everybody goes back to work presumably
people are gonna start spreading
coronavirus again Ben cowling professor
and head of the division of Epidemiology
and biostatistics at Hong Kong
University School of Public Health he
says it's very clear the actions taken
in China have almost brought to an end
their first wave of infections the
question is what will happen if there's
a second wave because the kind of
measures China has implemented are not
necessarily sustainable in the long term
which of course is sort of the point
that I'm making here these measures we
are taking here are not sustainable in
the long term which which does raise the
as to what everything looks like on the
other side of this and and meanwhile in
the United States obviously we are
seeing spikes in the number of diagnosed
cases that makes sense because we were
seeing spikes in the number of tests
that are available in New York City did
something like 7,000 tests yesterday so
it's not a big surprise that you saw a
spike in the number of cases identified
in New York there's apparently a huge
spike in the Brooklyn Hasidic community
more than a hundred people testing
positive into neighborhoods all at two
urgent care centers crammed with worried
families according to the New York Times
health officials expressed growing alarm
on Wednesday that the corona virus is
spreading quickly in tightly knit acidic
Jewish communities in Brooklyn saying
they're investigating a spike in
confirmed cases in recent days which is
one of the reasons guys listen I'm an
Orthodox Jew so like don't go to Mass
weddings idiots stop it anybody who's
doing that sort of stuff of any religion
like stop stop okay now is the time when
you actually want to allow the
government to increase the number of
beds available allow the private sector
to increase the number of masks
available right all we are doing is
buying time so let the time be bought
don't ignore the warnings and go out and
party it up at a wedding in somebody's
backyard I saw tape with that yesterday
floating around like just don't do that
okay there's one thing to go overboard
like some people are doing saying don't
go to a park even if you're doing social
like go out to a park socially distance
all that's good do not interact in
exactly all the normal ways of a bar
like porn was last week okay there was a
party down the block and this is before
sort of everybody had decided that that
we're all gonna go into quarantine
effectively and I turned to my wife and
my parents and I said I think that's a
bad idea and we ended up not going and
said we just did something in our house
like just do that hey just do that more
than a hundred people have recently
tested positive for corona virus in
Borough Park and Williamsburg to
Brooklyn neighborhoods with sizable
Hasidic Jewish populations all of them
tested a - urgent care centers that have
been crowded with anxious patients
according to an urgent care center
employee on Tuesday bill de blasio said
that the city would begin to increase
its testing capacity from the current
level of several hundred tests a day the
increase would start on Thursday with
the expectation of reaching the goal of
5,000 tests a day after several days de
Blasio said that there were no known
clusters of corona virus in the city but
there are certainly clusters in certain
areas of Brooklyn apparently meanwhile
there's also breaking news that a number
of of people who've come
with coronavirus and are now being
hospitalized are under the age of 54
they're saying that 40% of patients sick
enough to be hospitalized were aged 20
to 54 but for all of the talk about the
serious consequences to young people and
there are some serious consequences
you've seen decreased lung capacity in
some young people for example the fact
is this remains still a disease that is
basically killing off older people the
proof coming not courtesy of the United
States but coming courtesy instead of
Italy where there are studies
demonstrating that literally 99% of
people dying from the virus had other
illnesses according to the Italian
government bloomberg reported this
yesterday more than 99% of Italy's
coronavirus fatalities were people who
suffered from previous medical
conditions according to a study by the
country's national health authority
after deaths from the virus reached more
than 2,500 with 150 percent increase in
the past week health authorities have
been combing through data to provide
clues to help combat the spread of the
disease Prime Minister
Giuseppe Conte's government is
evaluating whether to extend a
nationwide lockdown beginning the
beginning of April apparently they're
going to do this italy has more than 30
1,500 confirmed cases of the illness
more than 75 percent of the people who
have died in italy had high blood
pressure 35 percent had diabetes 1/3
suffered from heart disease the median
age of those infected was 63 the median
age of death was 80 point five as the
median age of death the average age is
seventy nine point five so this is still
a disease that is almost entirely
killing old people and and people with
pre-existing conditions that does not
mean we shouldn't take it seriously if
we're young I mean it can be a carrier
of this thing of course but the fact
remains that if we have done all we can
do in terms of increasing our medical
capacity then and that has not happened
yet as we're about to discuss if we get
to the point where here we have maxed
out our medical capacity at that point
people are gonna start going to work and
sort of the chips are gonna fall where
they may
that's just the realistic nature of this
thing now with that said we are still
running way behind with regard to
testing we're still running way behind
with regards to beds we're still running
way behind with regard to face masks
we're gonna get to all of that in one
second I'm going to talk about how the
federal government did indeed screw this
thing up and how the fact is the private
industry is now having to fill the gap
we'll get to all of that in just one
second first let's talk of
the reality you must know your business
down to the nitty-gritty right now is
like the best time to know your business
down to the nitty gritty it's one thing
to know your business really well in up
times in down times and emergency times
you really do need to know what is
required to run your business the only
way that you can do that is to have all
the data on your business in front of
you and available at a moment's touch
this is why you need NetSuite companies
like ring hint to Kovas they all use
NetSuite if you want to take your
company from 2 million to 10 million or
10 million to hundreds of millions in
revenue
NetSuite by Oracle gives you the tools
to turbocharge your growth with NetSuite
you've got a full picture of your
business finance inventory HR customers
and more it's everything you need to
grow all in one place run your entire
business from anywhere even if you're
working from home with NetSuite you are
indeed covered NetSuite will give you
the visibility and control you need to
make the right decisions and grow with
conference that's why NetSuite customers
grow faster than the S&P 500 NetSuite is
the world's number one cloud business
system trusted by more than 19,000
companies it is indeed the last system
you will ever need NetSuite because
business grows here schedule your free
products tour right now receive your
free guide six ways to run a more
profitable business at NetSuite comm
slash men again that's NetSuite comm
/ban NetSuite comm slash man make your
business more efficient by checking out
the data in NetSuite comm slash BEM all
righty well as I say the medical
shortages are continuing the Centers for
Disease Control and Prevention are now
attempting to give people information
about what they can do to replace face
masks if they are short on face masks
they have contingency and crisis
strategies their contingency capacity
strategies are that they include
extended use of face masks so wearing
the same face mask for repeated closed
contacts and counselors with several
different parties without removing the
face mask between patient encounters the
face mask should be removed in discard
of soil damaged or hard to breathe
through according to the CDC also
restrict face masks to use by healthcare
professionals rather than patients for
source control and finally they are
suggesting that not only should you
possibly implement limited reuse of face
masks which apparently is being done at
hospitals they're suggesting other
different options including using a face
shield that covers the entire front that
extends to the chin or below and the
sides of the face with no face mask
considering the use
ventilated headboards or using homemade
masks they say in settings where face
masks are not available healthcare
professionals might use homemade masks
like bandanas or scarfs for care of
patients with Kovan 19 as a last resort
homemade masks are not considered
patient safe since their capability to
protect is unknown caution should be
exercised when considering this option
homemade masks should ideally be used in
combination with a facial that covers
the entire front and sides of the face
obviously the fact that the CDC is
issuing such guidance tells you
something about exactly how far behind
we are on all of this meanwhile there
are serious questions to be asked about
why the tests were not available as I
say South Korea on a on a per capita
basis the United States is testing far
less than nearly any industrialized
country and that is due to failures by
the CDC and the federal government the
CDC turndown testing kits from the w-h-o
they said they developed their own and
then it turns out that they were giving
all sorts of false positives and maybe
even some false negatives according to
The Wall Street Journal when cases of
the new corona virus began emerging
several weeks ago in California
Washington in other pockets of the
country US public health officials
worried this might be the big one
according to emails and interviews the
testing program they rolled out to
combat it though was a small one limited
testing has blinded Americans to the
scale of the outbreak so far impeding
the nation's ability to fight the virus
through isolating the sick and their
contacts according to public health
officials as of early on Wednesday about
6500 people in the United States had
tested positive by the way it is now
Thursday obviously and we're talking
about north of 10,000 the CDC and
Prevention had reported only about
32,000 tests conducted at its facilities
and other public health labs limited
testing was keeping patients in the dark
despite recent improvements people are
coming in with these symptoms of korenev
iris and they are being told that they
actually should not be tested unless
they know they were in contact to
someone with corona virus but the
problem is that nobody's been tested for
corona virus so how the hell do you know
if you're in contact with somebody who
has corona virus well the virus was
quietly spreading within the United
States the CDC had told state and local
officials its testing capacity is more
than adequate to meet current testing
demands according to a February 26 the
agency email viewed by The Wall Street
Journal the agency's data show it tested
fewer than a hundred patients that day
okay some some people are gonna be fired
for this and should be fired for this
when the CDC first dispersed
test kits in early
it shipped them to a network of state
and local government labs and restricted
testing to people with virus symptoms
who had recently traveled to China but
it was already weeks too late for that
federal officials hope the virus could
be contained even as they disputed
alarms from those on the front lines
that CDC's guidelines weren't keeping up
with the outbreaks spread
according to emails between the u.s.
agency and local officials and there are
people who are going to blame the the
Trump administration for this but it
just demonstrates that when you have a
very thick bureaucracy that people tend
to cover their own asses which is
something that obviously we already knew
the narrow effort is a failing said
Anthony Fauci government doctors become
the de facto face of the Trump
administration coronavirus response
while problems clearly still persist
more labs are beginning to do tests
manufacturers are ramping up a
production cDC officials botched an
initial test kit developed in an agency
lab retracting many tests they resisted
calls from state officials and medical
providers to broaden testing health
officials failed to coordinate with
outside companies to ensure needed test
kit supplies like nasal swabs and
chemical reagents would be available
according to suppliers and health
officials when the FDA finally opened
testing two more outside labs a run on
limited stocks of some supplies needed
for the CDC develop tests quickly
depleted stores according to lab
operators and suppliers hospital and
commercial lab operators said the
government didn't reach out to enlist
their help until it was too late
so obviously this continues to be a
giant failing now we are ramping up the
testing and that is a good thing if we
do wish to move that said at the outset
from the sort of Chinese model of lock
everything down to the South Korean
model of we gotta test as many people as
humanly possible and then lock down the
people who have this thing then the
testing regime is gonna have to be a lot
larger and we're late on this but we are
getting the test out now with that said
there are serious questions to be asked
about whether even the South Korean
response is going to be sufficient
considering the fact that South Korea
may be experiencing a secondary spike
but as soon as the as soon as people are
entering South Korea again it's possible
to South Korea sees a secondary spike as
I mentioned earlier we are seeing second
waves of the virus that are breaking out
all across Asia experts are warning of
second waves all across Asia so if that
happens the question is going to be
whether testing is going to be
sufficient which really means that in
and what we're gonna have to deal with
is the sad reality that maybe the best
we can do is just mitigate the effects
of this thing meaning we develop better
treatments there's some people have been
saying that anti malarial treatments
might work there was some hope that anti
HIV treatments would work those
apparently have failed anti malarial
treatments are now being tested there's
gonna be a lot of talk about ICU beds
and ventilators all of that is perfectly
appropriate it is possible the testing
is not going to be the cure-all that a
lot of people seem to think that it is
again the reason the reason for that
we'll explain in just one minute first
let's talk for a second about staying at
home all day you're looking at your
windows you're trying to improve your
house I know a lot of people right now
have you ever had a spring cleaning
season quite like this one yeah I'm at
home right now and I will say this my
wife and I are finally cleaning out of
storage all that old stuff and throwing
it away all it took was a giant global
pandemic to make all that happen well if
you're sitting around looking your house
and think how can you improve this thing
without leaving your home I have a great
solution for you
blinds.com make your home more beautiful
it's easy and affordable with blinds.com
the number one online retailer of custom
window treatments whether you want them
to handle everything with your new
measure and install services or you want
to do it yourself you'll enjoy the
blinds.com treatment particularly good
in times when you are not supposed to
leave your home every order gets free
samples free shipping it's truly free to
talk to a professional designer
blinds.com has no hidden fees or
misleading quotes unlike some other
places plus their 100% satisfaction
guarantee means if you aren't totally
satisfied with the style color or
quality of her window treatments
blinds.com will remake them for free it
really is an easy way to make your house
look a thousand times better go to
blinds.com for the best quality window
treatments at low prices and for a
limited time my listeners save 15% or
more plus an extra 20 bucks off with
promo code been save fifteen percent or
more on the best looking blinds shades
and shutters plus an extra twenty bucks
off at blinds comm with promo code ben
blinds.com promo code ben rules and
restrictions do apply ok so as I say one
of the reasons that mitigation might in
the end be the only thing that is
available to us is because even an
additional testing regimen has its
downsides there's a good piece by my
friend Sean trend over at
RealClearPolitics all about the perils
of mass coronavirus testing
he says tests can availability aside
there are crucial issues to consider for
example so long as the background level
of infection is low there are real down
smash testing and good reasons to limit
testing to individuals who show symptoms
or have been in contact with people who
have shown symptoms the problem is that
when the overall level of infection is
low the overwhelming majority of your
positive test results from mask testing
will be false positives so maybe the
regimen that was put in place in the
United States actually would be
preferable once we have the beds in
place rather than the mass testing and
then the mass quarantine of people who
show up positive here is the reason
because let's say for example that you
have a test in which there is a false
positive rate of one in ten and let's
say that there's a threat from dr.
sterling herring at Vanderbilt
University talking about this so what
happens if everybody is tested if tests
were perfect that would be great but
nearly all tests come with errors the
quick test used in South Korean
drive-throughs generates an error
roughly one in ten times so let's assume
that we tested everyone with a 90%
accurate test so you'd end up with a set
of results in which let's say that you
tested a hundred thousand people who
have who actually have corona virus okay
you know that they have thrown away risk
well you'd end up with is ninety
thousand positive tests and ten thousand
negative tests okay now let's say that
you test a million people right now or
10 million people hey if you test ten
million people okay a huge number of
people like you test everybody the
number of false positives actually is
going to vastly outweigh the number of
true positives because again most of the
people who have the virus are gonna get
a positive reading but the people who
don't have illness ten percent of those
people are gonna get a positive reading
too since there are far more people that
don't have the virus then do have at a
ten percent error group for that rate
overwhelms the 90% accuracy rate for the
group that does have it so you end up
with a scenario where literally 93
percent of the people who test positive
for disease do not in fact have the
disease so this can certainly skew your
data because you could see the
relatively low mortality rate and assume
that that's real because the problem
with widespread testing a lot of people
who test positive won't actually have
had the disease in the first place
second it gives people a false sense of
confidence because that low death rate
means okay fine maybe I'll just go out
and play and finally you're gonna end up
with the situation in which a lot of
people are kept home who are actually
healthy
so maybe NASA testing is not in fact a
panacea a panacea
depending on you know whether or not
these tests are supremely accurate and
if there's a second wave then even the
South Korean sort of solution may not
work which means in the end the lockdown
policies are bound to do not they cannot
be long-term there is no lockdown policy
that is long-term it is possible that
even a mask testing regimen
statistically speaking cannot be a
long-term solution and this is certainly
the case when you're talking about
walking down the economy to the extent
that we have so let's talk about the
federal government's response to all of
this so I'm at the federal government
which is now intervening on an
unprecedented scale in in the financial
community and in the in the economy now
there are a lot of people who have been
saying I've been getting a lot of emails
you're a libertarian why aren't you
protesting at the government getting the
solves in the economy because what we
have here is essentially a regulatory
taking so under the takings Clause of
the Fifth Amendment you cannot seize
private property for public use without
just compensation when you effectively
shut down every business in the country
by executive Fiat maybe through love
through mayors or through states or
through the federal government you are
preventing people from using the
property you're effectively taking their
property from them and the ability to
use their property from them without any
sort of just compensation this is not
the situation when they're sort of just
a normal economic downturn or when the
market just collapses for no external
externality driven reason in this
particular case is not even the disease
that's shutting down the economy per se
the disease would have an impact on the
economy but if we were all going to work
right now the stock market wouldn't
dropped 33% right the stock market
wouldn't dropped from 30,000 down below
20,000 one of the reasons all this is
happening is specifically because
governments around the world have
forcibly stepped in and shut down
businesses from operating so the
government shoring things up or at least
freezing things in place until such time
as people can get back to work make some
sense again they can't seize your
property without just compensation just
compensation presumably would include
ensuring the economy continues to work
in your business doesn't fail while the
government forces you to close so
President Trump put out a message
yesterday he said we will prevail
together again that that's a good
message to be putting out there here's
what we need a timeline is I'm going to
continue to discuss in just a moment
you've heard it a thousand times
wash your hands good hygiene all of that
but social distancing keep away it's
going to have no place to go
just want to thank you as president I
want to thank you for the incredible job
you are all doing this spirit in our
country like never before we are really
we've pulled together as a unit we
pulled together as a country we will
prevail together we love the USA okay
well yeah that's I'm sure we all do the
president also says we're unleashing the
full power of the federal government
which of course is true the question is
for how long because the bottom line is
this if you are at all concerned about
government power which I'm a
conservative I am this stuff better be
temporary there's a long history in the
United States of crises being used to
massively grow government then the
government never goes back to its
original boundaries which is why we have
to be pretty careful about the sort of
measures we implement and we have to be
pretty clear that these measures are
designed to sunset as soon as the
lockdown is over here's President from
talking about the extent of the federal
government's response we're using the
full power in response to the Chinese
virus I declared a state of national
emergency that will make up 250 billion
dollars in disaster relief funds
available which we can use to assist
hospitals which as you know we need yeah
all of that is true so what exactly is
in the relief bills that have been
signed so far so yesterday president
from signed a bill providing paid sick
leave free testing other benefits
according to the New York Times a relief
package to provide sick leave
unemployment benefits free coronavirus
testing and food and medical aid to
people affected by the pandemic was
signed into law by President Trump on
Wednesday evening after the Senate
passed it by a wide margin it was
approved in the house last week the
Senate vote was 90 to 8 after the
majority leader senator Mitch McConnell
urged conservatives who disliked the
bill to gag and vote for it anyway he
says we have to do something this is
this is one of the dangers of politics
is that the urgent often defeats the
good meaning that those who are calling
for immediate action they're not wrong
we do need immediate action right now to
shore up the economy make sure that
people aren't going to go hungry make
sure that people continue to be able to
live in their homes all that has to
happen the problem is that when you have
an emergency situation that is also a
fantastic time as rahm emanuel ones but
it never let a good crisis go to waste
it's also a great time to load up bills
with enormous levels of pork and then
hope that everybody just goes over on
with it because the political cost of
not going along with it is a lot higher
than just signing the check for the
moment lawmakers are already
drafting another economic stabilization
package that would send direct payments
to taxpayers and provide loans to
businesses mcconnell said we're moving
rapidly because of the situation demands
it there's an outline of the new package
it calls for a total of 1 trillion
dollars in spending that included fifty
billion dollars for secured loans for
the airline industry not grants right
loans the airline industry which
presumably they'll have to pay back
another 150 billion dollars for secured
loans or loan guarantees for other parts
of the economy it would allow the
exchange Stabilization Fund an emergency
reserve account usually used for
currency market interventions to be
tapped to cover the costs it would also
temporarily guaranteed money market
mutual funds the Treasury Department
proposal calls for two rounds of checks
sent directly to American taxpayers
April 6th and May 18th payments will
depend on the recipients income and
family size according to the summary
each round would disperse 250 billion
dollars now again these big bailouts are
basically designed to keep everybody
afloat for the moment but the temptation
is going to be from the government keep
these things permanent right this is why
you're seeing so many people suggest
that a two thousand dollar one-time
payout is equivalent to Andrew Yang's
1,000 a month payment to everybody
forever these two things are different
and everybody should make very clear in
their minds that these two things are
different these are not the same okay
you cannot claim that a permanent
program is the same as a temporary
program nor should conservatives be
sucked into thinking that a permanent
program is the same as a temporary
program Lincoln suspended habeas corpus
that was not a permanent feature of
American life FCR violated nearly every
rule of American Civil Liberties during
World War two that was not a permanent
feature of American life none of this
should become a permanent feature of
American life in times of good economic
health because it does provide
disincentive to work now the problem
right now is that there is no work to be
had because the federal government has
shut everything down and so on the state
and local local governments it is one
thing for these state and local
governments to rectify their breach by
preventing the entire economy from
collapsing when they're the ones who are
causing this in the first place it is
another thing for the federal government
and the state governments to simply
create a whole new set of incentives
during a non time of crisis which is I
think what people want it's why I
suggest it's why Republicans I think
correctly are bucking against the the
Democratic attempts to force small
businesses forever to pay for paid sick
leave the reason being who's not going
to take the paid sick leave if you can
take the paid sick leave every year of
course you
you just raised the cost on businesses
now in a time like this I still think
it's not great policy I think that if
the government wants to pay for that the
government can pay for that and they can
borrow on that basis and will pay for it
later
forcing small businesses to pay paid
sick leave when they barely I mean they
can't even cover their employees me
people are getting furloughed right now
you're actually causing people to get
fired but even if you were to be in
favor of it right now that doesn't mean
that you should be in favor of it
permanently again these sort of
libertarian conservative case here is
when the federal government shuts down
businesses they need to compensate
businesses for shutting them down it
will get to more of this in just one
second what these policies look like and
then we will we will ask you know again
how long is this gonna last what what's
the policies look like in the future and
we'll get to the media's laser-like
focus on the real issue here which is
why are we calling it the Chinese virus
because we have to focus on the dumbest
possible stuff okay well in the meantime
you having trouble sleeping these days
well maybe one of the reasons you're
having trouble sleeping they haven't
even thought about is the blue light
from your computer right your check
you're scrolling you're checking you're
checking the news every time you how
could you not check the news every five
seconds in this environment well I'm not
saying that you have to shut down the
screen I am saying the what you really
should have is a set of Felix gray
glasses why because exposure to blue
light especially and I can lower the
production of melatonin the hormone that
regulates sleep situations prone ties
strain include bright screens in a dark
room Felix gray glasses they're like a
sunscreen for your eyes Felix gray
filters out 90% of blue light in the
most damaging range Felix grape frames
are hand finished from durable super
lightweight Italian acetate 95% of Felix
gray buyers routinely wear them report
significant symptom relief so if you're
looking at a computer late at night this
will help you it'll also help if you
just get some eye strain from looking in
a computer all day long like I do Felix
gray is available in prescription
non-prescription and readers whether
you're staying home right now and just
keeping track of the news and doing your
work or whether you are watching a lot
of Netflix Felix gray can help you sleep
better Felix gray can help that your
eyes don't strain prevent you from
getting headaches go to Felix great
glasses calm / Ben for the absolute best
quality blue light filtering glasses on
the market that is Fe Li X GRA Y Felix
gray glasses calm / Ben do what we did
start taking care of your eyes feel
better work smarter I have Felix gray
glasses I use them to shipping and
returns are totally free at Felix gray
Felix great glasses calm / Ben Felix
great glasses calm /ban go check them
out right now felix cray glasses calm /
pen and you can order them online by the
way try them for 30 days risk-free if
the screens aren't he's your under s and
back for a full refund that's felix greg
glasses comm slash man okay we're gonna
get to more of the proposals being put
forward by the federal government are
they permanent or are they temporary and
they say very large difference first if
you haven't had a chance to check out
some of our new content that we started
this week called all-access live should
head over to daily wire comm and check
it out jeremy boring and i kicked it off
monday evening
jeremy and michael moles followed up on
tuesday night Matt Walsh was last night
we're doing episodes of the rest of the
week at 8 p.m. Eastern 5 p.m. Pacific
I'll be doing another episode on Friday
as well if you're wondering what I'll
access live is about well it's really
relaxed I mean it's basically just us
hanging out I remember I will take
credit for this who's sort of my idea in
the sense that I remember being back in
law school and being stuck in a dorm
during the winter and being like god
this is annoying and lonely and I wish
that I had somebody to hang out with so
I got married in any case right now
since everybody's locked down it's a
great time to hang out with us these
shows are less focused on bringing news
and information more about just hanging
out with you at the end of a long day
we're all kind of stuck in isolation
right now it's more important than ever
we come together as a community and hang
out together I think these live streams
with our audience help us bring us
together even though it's through a
computer the show is intended for our
all access members but during the
national emergency and this time of
isolation and social annoyance
we've opened it up to all of our members
in doing so we've accelerated the launch
so please let us know what you think of
it if you're around at 8 p.m. Eastern 5
p.m. pacific tonight join us on the
all-access live show over at daily
wire.com you're listening to the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
as according to the New York Times
entire sectors of the American economy
are shutting down threatening to crush
businesses put millions of people out of
work
forcing lawmakers to consider a vast
financial bailout that would dwarf the
federal government's response to the
2008 crisis again one of the reasons
this is appropriate is because it's the
government that is causing this now I'm
not saying it's unjust that it's
unjustified what the government is doing
as I've suggested it's justified so long
as there is a plan after the next two
weeks next three weeks if there's no
plan than it is unjustified if the
government has no plan if we have not up
to our resources if all we've done is
destroy the world economy to buy us no
time and to not fix anything and not
increase our capacity then this was a
complete waste but if we've actually
bought some time if we've increased in
the curve in some way if we have if we
have increased our medical capacity well
then maybe this all will have been worth
it at least to a large extent but that
doesn't mean that the government gets to
shut down your business and then not
compensate you for shutting down your
business when you haven't violated the
law in any way the economist feared that
by the time the corona virus pandemic
subsides and economic activity resumes
entire industries could be wiped out
proprietors across the country could
lose their businesses millions of
workers could find themselves at jobless
that of course is true and it's one of
the reasons why we should carefully
consider exactly the measures that we're
taking with an eye toward what's gonna
happen in a month if you're just if
we're doing this by the seat of our
pants day by day that is not going to
cut it there had better be a plan if
you're talking about wrecking the world
economy there'd better be a plan cuz you
know it's funny there are there people
out there particularly in Twitter world
who say if you even mention the economy
at this time you're not taking human
lives seriously enough would you care
more about dollars in GDP or human life
let's be clear about this people losing
their jobs that actually affects human
life people losing the businesses
they've invested their life savings in
that kind of affects human life millions
and millions of people losing their jobs
all at once in a massive shock to the
economy that's gonna have some real-life
ramifications for all the people who
lose their jobs and their children and
their spouses and the people they care
about so let's not pretend there no
costs on the other side and let's not
pretend that there are no cost
calculations when it comes to
calibrating strategy properly when one
of the things that is always bad policy
is when you say if only it would save
one life it would only save one life
then we'd cut out all cars again none of
this is to argue that we shouldn't be
taking the measures we're taking right
now maybe we should but there had bet I
keep saying it over and over I'm gonna
keep saying it there'd better be a plan
on the other side that plan had
better involve vastly increased capacity
to deal with us it better involve some
mitigating technologies it better
involve better testing facilities and it
better involve people getting back to
work as soon as possible because this
cannot this cannot maintain and there's
been some talk from from doctors about
what's going to happen over the next 12
to 18 months are we gonna go through
periodic rounds of sort of area
shutdowns if there's an outbreak
maybe that has to happen but the
question is the broad overarching
consequences of all of this and so
Washington can take on debt but it can't
take on debt forever and it does
demonstrate by the way that we were
idiots to take out on 22 trillion
dollars of debt for no reason over the
past 40 years geniuses all now we
actually need to max out the credit card
and we've been busy maxing it out on
garbage that we bought on eBay so blunt
the fallout Washington is weighing
proposals that could easily top true
trillion dollars a staggering jump from
the initial eight point three billion
dollar virus responsible lawmakers
approved this month that does include
that one trillion dollar request that
President Trump was making the
Republicans are also weighing a separate
proposal that would extend the trillion
dollars and assistance to small
businesses to keep them afloat during
the outbreak and keep workers on their
payrolls I don't truly like the idea of
the federal government giving direct
loans to small businesses honestly
because the federal government has an
interest then in making sure that nobody
pays all that back who's gonna be the
person who enforces that instead the
federal government should be giving
loans to the banks that underwrite all
these small businesses and floating them
loans at basically zero percent Interest
and telling them they only get those
loans if they don't call in the loans
right now and that'd be the best way to
calibrate all of this so that is sort of
the situation where we stand all of this
needs to be temporary we do need to get
back to normal and back to normal is the
thing that has to happen there's got to
be a plan for this I'm not the only
person asking this question I think
everybody is asking this question at
this point The Associated Press has a
piece today called how long will
Americans be fighting the corona virus
scientists say there isn't a simple
answer
Stephen Moore's disease researcher at
Columbia says in many ways the situation
is unprecedented we're trying to take
some actions to curb the spread in
timing of the pandemic he says there
have been past disease outbreak
scientists can draw lessons from but in
those cases the disease was largely
allowed to run its course so the models
don't precisely apply this is correct
obviously I mean the fact is that if we
didn't care about human life which of
course we do then
allow the disease to run its course it
would wipe out whoever wipes out and
people just continue to operate as
normal the whole point of this is
presumably that we are going to prevent
the loss of life but the question is how
you best how you best minimize loss of
life without also destroying an economy
that sustains life and what do you think
happens in impoverished countries that
are reliant on the world economy in
order to feed people right people in the
United States will still get fed for 12
to 18 month period of time that is not
true in countries that are there in the
developing world or in the undeveloped
world on Monday President Trump said the
u.s. may be managing the outbreak
through July or August New York Governor
Andrew Cuomo said the states number of
coronavirus cases may peak not end in 45
days each model of how the disease could
spread relies on data and assumptions
about population dynamics demographics
health care capacity and other factors
according to Rebecca Katz public health
expert at Georgetown the challenge for
designing models what will happen next
is that limited testing for Kovan 19
means researchers don't even know that
the starting point is how many people
are already infected
so how long is this thing actually going
to last well mark Jett disease
researchers London School of Hygiene and
Tropical Medicine says the points of the
restrictions we actually we have is
actually to stretch this out even longer
we don't want a big peak to come very
quickly so how does this end most
scientists believe that the fight
against Kovan 19 won't be over until
there's an effective at vaccine but that
could take more than a year the best
case scenario according to JIT is that
we have a vaccine in 12 or 18 months our
lives go back to normal the worst case
scenarios it takes a long time for the
vaccine to be developed the world is
really changed our lives aren't the same
again ever but nobody thinks that we're
gonna be shut-ins forever nobody thinks
that's going to happen Michael Levy
University of Pennsylvania disease
researcher II says I don't think we can
maintain social distancing as it is
right now for the duration of the
epidemic that obviously is true I mean
you have idiots in Florida who are out
partying on the beaches like right now
you think they're gonna last another
another year well I mean like really
they're not gonna last another five
minutes well maybe more feasible is the
instrument restrictions and enhanced
monitoring to control the disease ones
the number of new cases falls below a
certain threshold schools offices
restaurants could reopen if the number
of infection spikes again restrictions
would be reinstated it's gonna be very
difficult to reinstate restrictions
after the restrictions come off is part
of the problem here bouncing around
between restricted and non restrictive
is gonna be very difficult and this is
particularly true when you look at the
at the data at home and Jenkins over The
Wall Street Journal has a piece today
talking specifically about the
statistics on coronavirus and what
exactly are the costs that we're willing
to undergo as an economy in order to
minimize an unspecified number of deaths
we actually don't know the answers to
how many deaths are actually being
prevented right now Holman Jenkins says
some number of respiratory deaths will
be avoided really delayed but we'll be
spending a lot more than we've ever been
willing to spend before to avoid flu
deaths eighty-three percent of our
economy will be suppressed to relieve
pressure on the 17% represented by
healthcare this will have to last months
not weeks to modulate the rate at which
a critical mass of 330 million get
infected and acquire natural immunity
well people will put at will people put
up with it once they realize they're
still expected to get the virus right
again this is why it really is about
increasing ICU capacity because we don't
increase ICU capacity and people like I
can either get it now or I can wait and
not have a job and get it later
if I can be like I'll get it now
seriously I don't I can't tell you how
many people who are you know in their
20s and 30s I've talked to over the past
few days who have been like if I could
just get this thing right now and then
be done with it I would do it if I knew
I wasn't gonna carry it to Grandma and
that's gonna be an increasing attitude
as people lose their jobs so the
questions become if we can't actually
increase capacity if things are what
they are at that point you just have to
let this thing go right that is sort of
the logic that is happening right now
understandably says homeand jenkins
politicians believe faith and government
requires avoiding italy leg scenes but
turned on its head here is the 50 year
old QALY revolution the idea of
measuring the burden of disease and
benefit of health care based on quality
adjusted life year typically valued at
50 to 150 thousand dollars in the
presence in the present instance the
cost isn't just medical intervention
like ventilator use but the cost of an
economy-wide shutdowns limit the number
of candidates for ventilation at any one
time he says I don't know what the
figure is but the QALY value were
placing on avoiding Italy like deaths is
surely a high multiple of any figure
previously considered realistic
America's shut down strategy is
interesting because it was not a choice
that any one person or authority made
everybody sort of jumped on board
overnight but this can't last
indefinitely is the point that Holman
Jenkins is making and that's right we
are operating in the absence of data so
here's the bottom line in several weeks
we will have data once those data are
there we are going to
to make a choice about what we can do
from here because this just isn't
sustainable everybody knows it's not
sustainable and the government needs to
lay out like we need to know and we need
to Beit openly what are the conditions
under which we go back to normal what
are the virus vectors under which we go
back to normal
what can we expect over the next 12 to
18 months until a vaccine is developed
because a permanent shutdown is not in
the cards it is just not a thing it's
just not a thing okay meanwhile the
media continue to carry water many in
the media continue to carry water for
China which is unbelievable because
China is indeed responsible for the
growth of this virus for the release of
this virus not by the military or
anything but as I mentioned yesterday -
apparently some ballyhoo online China's
refusal to shut down web markets which
by the way our animal rights abuses
since it's amazing how many people on
the Left are very much against animal
rights if it's by the way so am i I saw
some people like why don't you talk
about factory farming and conditions I
have before have you not listened to the
show I've talked about how vegetarianism
might actually be more moral in the end
I mean I have talked about this the web
markets in China are a disaster area
they've been responsible for several
outbreaks of different types ranging
from the so-called Asian flu of the
1950s to what we are watching right now
and the fact that China had two SARS I
mean the fact that China has allowed
this stuff to to militate and then as it
has allowed it to to spread among
populations of the world is entirely
China's fault
Axios compiled an actual timeline of
what the Chinese government did they say
that if Chinese authorities had acted
three weeks earlier than they did the
number of coronavirus cases could have
been reduced by 95% they put together
this entire timeline and it demonstrates
that the the Chinese government knew
they silenced it they refused to allow
the information to spread they lied to
the w-h-o and said that it did not have
human to human transmission they allowed
tens of thousands of people to gather
for events they'll have some five
million people apparently to travel out
of when okay then the China is
responsible for all of this this hasn't
stopped the media from in their
desperate hatred of Trump trying to
pretend that Trump is a racist for
pointing out that China is responsible
for all of this here's yesterday
President Trump going at it with a
reporter who could he was asked this
question like four separate times
seriously in all of this your biggest
concern is that we are labeling China
bad actor Wyndham you know China is the
bad actor why do you keep calling this
the Chinese virus there are reports of
dozens of incidents of bias against
Chinese Americans in this country your
own a secretary a czar and says he does
not use this term because ethnicity does
not cause the virus why are you keep
using this letter comes injury exist
that's not racist at all now let it okay
it comes from China that's why comes
from China I want to be accurate there
please John I have a great I have great
love for all of the people from our
country but as you know China tried to
say at one point maybe this stuff now
that it was caused by American soldiers
that can't happen it's not gonna happen
not as long as I'm president it comes
from China he is right about all of this
everything he says here is true it is
not racist
it is not culturally insensitive to
point out that eating penguins and bats
has externalities and is a bad idea okay
for anyone yeah I don't think Americans
by the way like there are lots of things
that I think are yucky okay the question
is whether they cause externalities in
terms of whether they should be shut
down like I think that it's gross to eat
a raccoon I'm an Orthodox Jew I think
most things that people eat are gross
kosher but the reality is that China's
refusal to shut down these web markets
which are a an animal rights violation
beyond which they're now a human rights
violation considering how many people
are gonna die from this thing ten
trillion dollars gonna be lost from the
world economy over this whole thing and
you got the media defending them and B
she's Richard Engel yesterday pretending
that China has nothing to do with this
and that it really is just a rogue bat
you know it's those rogue bats going
around infecting people I guess people
were just sitting around the bat flew in
their mouths weird there was lots and
lots of scapegoating against an ethnic
group or a religious group whenever
there were pandemics that affected the
society and frightened a lot of people
and China certainly feels that is what
happened what is happening now with
people calling it the the Wuhan flu or
the Wuhan virus or the the China virus
this is a virus that came from the
territory of China but came from bats
this is a bat virus not a China virus it
doesn't speak Chinese it doesn't target
these people it targets human beings who
happen to touch their eyes nose or mouth
yeah really this is what you're doing
propaganda work on behalf of a Chinese
government that is actively attempting
to blame the West for the spread of a
virus that started under its Communists
garbage government Jimmy Kimmel doing
the same routine dunking on Trump is
more important than actually pointing
out the Chinese government is a horrific
dictatorship here is here's Jimmy Kimmel
trying to blame Trump for being mean did
to China or something from meanwhile has
a catchy little nickname for the
coronavirus he now calls it the Chinese
virus every chance he gets because you
know they say a great way to prevent a
virus from spreading is to name it
something racist that way people keep it
on the down-low I don't know why he does
this actually I do know why he does it's
to deflect blame away from him it's like
when he started calling Eric and Don
junior the ivana kids ridiculous
I'm sorry ridiculous this is not about
deflecting blame toward the Chinese
government the Chinese government
deserves the blame how are you guys all
defending China here how how is that
possible what the hell is wrong with you
people
Whoopi Goldberg does the same thing
mother nature did this toss not China
weird because it seems like the Chinese
government knew about this for like a
month
actively censored and threatened people
who ended up dying from coronavirus
released five million people from the
Wuhan province all over the world and
knew about this the whole time it seems
like that might have something to do
with the Chinese government according to
Whoopi Goldberg it's just Mother Nature
weird have they're willing to blame
mother nature when it comes to male
action by the Chinese government
malfeasance by the Chinese government
corruption and evil by the Chinese
government but when it comes to climate
change that's Trump's fault rights the
fault it's the fault of human beings
when it comes to climate change and lack
of action which may or may not be true
okay but when it comes to something that
is obviously the result of Chinese
governmental failures and evil then all
of a sudden well I guess it's just
nature and nature just took its own
course here unbelievable stuff we keep
talking about how we don't want to
politicize this which we shouldn't it's
right now it's a time to listen to
doctors look at information look at
facts look at data I think by calling it
the Chinese virus that's politicizing it
by title so I think we need to stay on
calling it what it is it's the corona
virus or covet 19 and stay with fact
mhm and you know people as we've seen
people start punching people
Asian folks out yes because you know
we'll attack so we need to stop calling
it or labeling it like it's they did it
to us mother nature really did this to
us okay first of all anybody who's going
like you know an ignorant stupid-ass you
have to be to go around punching Asian
people because you think that this is
the because this thing originated in
China like there is no you're full-scale
if you do that sort of thing
obviously and you should go to jail for
a significant period of time that's
called assault it's illegal and that
does not change the fact that the
Chinese government you want to call it
the commie virus I'm fine with that too
that's my mother way senator Ed Markey
who is no Republican and Democrat from
Massachusetts he says yeah we should
hold China accountable correct correct
China has imposed the temporary ban on
these markets but I think that China has
to be held accountable I think that the
World Health Organization the entire
world has to just say to China what they
would that you Anna did in keeping this
a secret even though they knew it was
happening is a disgrace it's causing
panic around the world and that is hips
absolutely something that the Chinese
must be called to account yeah okay that
is right that's right how is it that so
many people are left are blaming us on
the right when Ed Markey who is winger
is saying this it's obviously true okay
time for some things I like and then a
quick thing that I hate so things that I
like today as I've been mentioning all
show long when a crisis hits sometimes
you have to take crisis measures but
those crisis measures should not become
permanent there's a great book about
this by a guy named Robert Higgs it's
called crisis and Leviathan critical
episodes in the growth of American
government he makes the point that there
been a series of crises over the course
of American history they've constantly
been used to maximize the size and scope
of American government that doesn't mean
the temporary measures aren't necessary
it does mean that the temporary measures
very often are not temporary and we
should keep that in mind
when it comes to the crafting of bills
when it comes to the crafting of
legislation do not allow that there's no
reason that we should have to sign into
law at the behest of people who want to
make permanent a complete relational
break but
in the government and in citizens
there's no reason we have to cave to
that instead how about this how about we
work on what we have to do for the next
like 2-3 months and then we figure out
what to do two to three months after
that because I'll tell you what the
Democrats are gonna push for right now
they're gonna push for making permanent
to all of these changes to the American
economy that are fantastic in scope and
fantastical in impact and it's it's it's
going to be a disaster area unless we
keep in mind that it is only government
crackdowns that have caused what is
going on right now in the economy again
not unjustified but that is the reason
we are doing all this not because we
require a permanent change to the most
powerful economy in the history of the
world ok time for a quick thing that I
hate ok so as you all know the song
imagine is the worst song ever written
it is a horrible horrible evil song it's
not just evil because it's pretentious
and ridiculous and the piano chords and
all that it's an evil song because the
actual ethos that is promulgated by
imagine is completely idiotic imagine
there's no countries it's easy if you
try right ok so let's just be a little
frank about this right now it's pretty
obvious that our countries because every
single country on planet earth is
closing its borders to all of the other
countries and they talk about imagine
that the literacy would imagine there's
no heaven imagine there's no Hell right
all we care about is what happens here
on earth which of course would lead
pretty quickly to a moral breakdown of
society the song is just tremendously
horrible it's a horrible spunk with a
horrible immoral communists message I've
talked about it on the show extensively
before so naturally because celebrities
are idiots they decide that what would
be a great idea is to in the middle of
this pandemic cut a self-glorifying
video in which they each sing a line
from imagine because nothing says
solidarity quite like singing a no
borders idiotic communist song in the
middle of the pandemic in order to show
that you care also can anyone in
Hollywood like please come up with a
different idea for a video than
everybody's singing a line from a song
I'm not sure which is more irritating
this or the version of fight song they
did in 2016 for Hillary I think it's
this I think it's this here's a little
bit of a variety of celebrities
demonstrating how emotionally deep they
are by singing the dumbest song ever
penned
imagine there's no heaven miss gal gadot
easy if future
muttering all these lips imagine imagine
no countries Jimmy Fallon God is this
obnoxious garbage okay just stop it this
is the dumbest this is the dumbest song
ever imagine no religion in a time where
people are dying on mass imagine again
imagine no countries is a really weird
take when every border is shut it's a
very weird take like this is the song
that you choose I at least we are the
world had like a head like a solidarity
message that didn't include the
destruction of things that actually
prevent people from dying celebrities
these are the people that are moral
betters we should listen to Will Ferrell
on this stuff singing a minute like if
this is the height of your ethos Mark
Ruffalo singing imagine if the height of
your ethos is the song imagine it's
because you're doing morality wrong also
policy only dumb celebrities could come
up with the dumbest song ever and then
sing the dumbest song ever in order to
promote the dumbest agenda ever in the
face of a global pandemic that requires
concerted individual government action
and again significant restrictions on
our way of life unbelievable all right
well but perfectly believable because
celebrities are celebrities all right
we'll be back here a little bit later to
know two additional hours of content
otherwise we will see you here tomorrow
for all of your latest updates stay safe
out there and again as I say every day
we'll get through this together there is
an expiration date to the lockdown and
there's an expiration date to the effect
of the virus it may be sooner it may be
later but we can all hope and pray that
the government is taking the measures
necessary to at least get in place
treatments
and resources necessary to deal with the
pandemics that when the restrictions
come off we can get back to work I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show the
Ben Shapiro show is produced by Colton
Haas directed by Mike joiner executive
producer Jeremy boring supervising
producer
Mathis Glover and Robert Sterling
assistant director Pavel white house key
technical producer Austin Stevens
playback and media operated by Nick
Sheehan associate producer Katie Swinton
edited by Adam SIA vets audio is mixed
by Mike foramina hair and makeup is by
Anika Geneva the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 the market continues to
plummet as the Chinese coronavirus locks
people idle in their homes for weeks at
a time and the global economy grinds to
a halt we will compare the pandemic to
the left-wing policy agenda and see if
we can tell the difference then a new
study suggests the spread of the virus
could have been reduced by as much as
95% if the Chinese government had acted
to stop it rather than to cover it up
but of course instead of reporting on
that study the US mainstream media is
simply parroting the communist regimes
propaganda finally the mailbag check it
all out on the Michel Noel's show
[Music]